Jimmy I'm just gonna say it, I gotta let you go
You were just fired.
I was let go for liability reasons involving insurance.
The one-Armed Bartender
You need to show a little respect
Charlotte Motor Speedway
I know how they move the money
The only guy who knows anything about blowing up real bank vaults is Joe Bang
I am in-car-ce-ra-ted
Yeah we got a plan to get you out
The Coca-Cola 600 is the biggest race of the year. We need a computer whizz.
I know everything there is to know about computers.
Okay, all the Twitter's I know 'em
Welcome to the Coca-Cola 600
How many yards away is the vault? Twenty Yards.
I don't maybe thirty. Is it twenty or is it thirty? We are dealing with science here.
They're gonna know what we want 'em to know.
My life of crime is over.
That is massively stupid.
It's been handled.
Oh this is gonna be good.
That looks like it hurt.
I want everything on Jimmy Logan
I'm about to get naked so no peaking
I said no peaking!!
You Logans must be as simple minded as people say.
People say that?
Would you give me my arm please?
Is it this one?